the faces of businesses facing a future
that's unfamiliar the relief of
reopening for some the reality of new
rules for all I can no way to do to sit
down have a glass of sorry
blabla jamon iberico I can away at
Pizarro's excitement exudes they've been
surviving as a shot one meter distancing
hair will cut the capacity by half is
not ideal but two meters would have been
impossible it's gonna be par for
everything but it's important as well
that we can deliver safety safe
environment to our customer mmm and we
need to follow the rules to the joy of
many pubs in England we'll be back - at
the greyhound on the gallows tree it's
welcome but they're worried they'll have
to collect contacts from customers and
ensure safety is secured it won't be
easy
I think personally the fourth of July is
a crazy day to do it everything else has
been done on a Monday the 4th of July's
are Saturday when we know the world goes
absolutely mad and everyone wants to go
after the Saturday and we're going to
get wound when really if it started on
Monday we could break in gently
more people go to the cinema than to
football every weekend social distancing
is easier at screens than at stadiums
but the impact on margins remains it
often favors bigger businesses with
bigger premises it is going to cost us
more staffing wires everything is going
to be costing more and we are going to
be making less money so it's going to be
a struggle but we're we're lucky in our
instance because we have got a thousand
seats over five screens you can see in
the busyness of the streets life as we
knew it is gradually returning but it's
locked down left so to all the packages
of government support and for many like
gyms bowling alleys and swimming pools
you still have to remain shut surviving
is less certain than ever and that
includes nail salons we can have three
stations luckily this would be our first
station we would then skip this one then
this would be our second station Amma
has been preparing she's laid out the
space and ordered PPE for the staff her
government grant is almost gone she's
disappointed and worried
I know 80% furlough comes to an end in
July they haven't said what will happen
if you're in industry that is not
allowed to open past July if they'll
continue paying 80% and we'll need them
to carry on doing that for us to survive
as simple as that simple as that for
three months businesses have waited and
prepared but they can't control if
customers have the confidence to come
back many are still holding their breath
Helen Anne Smith Sky News